tieni carissima grazie carla ma è dura e
raccontami un po di marina da chi guarda
marina diventa anno dopo anno sempre più
servizievole gentile educata
ordinatissima camera assumo guarda è un
gioiellino 11 mamma ti dai da poco per
questa storia deve finire non te lo dico
canna ma voglio proprio una donna di
casa
l'altro giorno sono arrivata a casa
c'era tutta la tavola imbandita e una
cenetta coi fiocchi
c'è ma non è ancora fatta a mangiare i
lavori ricami tesoro aspetta un secondo
sto preparando iniziate da fare
chiaroscurale marian care vabbè dai
riposa dall'esordio dovresti vedere come
si veste e di un'eleganza di una
sobrietà innata giamaica esco rispetto
alle sue coetanee mario una parolaccia e
dell'educazione stellare carissima
mandarà dalle suore ha proseguito
qualcosa vabbè ma lui è un grandissimo
pezzo di ma poi nel capire sempre lì che
studia fermati nella sera a volte in tre
camere di comando smettere di studiare
targata guarda un film
guardò un dance flick marina è possibile
che non studi mai mamma ho fatto una
pausa dario po studio lonero però quante
pause fanali scusa quante bastano cioè
sempre difficile studiare non fuma vi
dico la linea dove sarai imam arrivo non
beve nemmeno cosa come questa volta
generavano e poi è super al tronista
carissima mette sempre gli altri il
primo posto prima stabilito la macchina
a digiuno verrà chiamo però c è stato
poco bene sono poi ospedale capito poi
non ha idea di quante su cui tali
stipendi che si attiva mente quando c'è
insomma abominio
meno male che di maria vergine
finalmente
basta